so the older models when you look at
forehead and you look at more young in
thought and there are still people who
really some who really use the Jungian
thought of dream analysis is really that
you and analyze the dreams the dreams
are there for a purpose for some people
they say it's about wish fulfillment
it's about the things that you never
able to do in your day you're actually
fulfilling at night there are other
people who will say that it's actually
telling you something if there's a lot
of fear that's going on if there's a lot
of anxiety it's manifesting itself in
your in your nocturnal world so that
analyzing it can help to open up
basically thoughts about what you need
to do during the day so a lot of people
who subscribe to the psychoanalysis the
onion thought will really focus a lot on
dreams the meaning and how it can be
used to help you during the day and as
you go to more modern thought they're
different it's actually quite a
controversial area there are some people
who believe that dreams really are just
kind of a throwaway thing they're just a
way of your brain processing what's
happened during the day but there's
really no meaning to them a lot of
imagery of just flashes of what happened
there are other people that think that
dreams actually do serve a purpose but
what that purpose is we're not really
sure so some people will believe that it
actually does have some psychological
representation of what's going on the
day but there's no need to sit and
really analyze it there are other people
who think like myself that dreams are
almost there a reenactment of what
happened during the day but it's a way
of you figuring out in your brain
processing to figure out what does it
need to hold on to and remember and what
can it just throw away so it's like your
brain has a large filing cabinet and
it's opening up each drawer and it's
taking in various images and memories
from the day consolidating what it needs
to and puts it in whatever file and then
if there's something that doesn't fit in
any of the files and doesn't really
belong you'll forget about it so it's a
way of really getting a succinct way of
abstain